happy Tuesday actually you're on
excitement then pregnant that's what I
thought you're pregnant I have a
designated driver for the next time on
you shouldn't congratulations thank you
so scary Oh am I allowed to move here
what do you mean Tom Ford doesn't make
onesies but long as you don't cry poop
or pee before mom gets back we got this
dad I'm so sorry this lady's over
already I can't believe it just blew by
I packed everything for you
uh I am not ready for a dog traffic was
so bad and I'm so sorry you've got
something there
oh my gosh oh it spit up oh definitely
stood up yeah yeah yeah it's not I just
think that it's okay it's not bad oh my
god you were getting so big and it's
just it's been so bad oh my god has she
done that before
these are her first steps these are her
first actual steps okay okay we got this
much like a little person go go go
oh no no no nope nope okay hi I think
you just you gotta just bend these like
these trays should come off or something
the test is like a loofah you know I saw
your first poop so you're not the only
person with my French
I'm so sad that this is ending right now
you are getting so big I cannot believe
that we yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah hey it's so fun
hey yeah hot and The Little Mermaid
decided to not give up her talent for
someone else and realize that she didn't
need a man to tell her anything
yes that that is the important part of
that book hmm that's how you throw shade
one more time okay one one more time we
just did one more time okay oh I can't
get that back oh yeah your mom's gonna
be here soon kind of wish you didn't
have to leave you want me to call your
mom and see if you can spend the night
sleepover yeah